ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I REAL
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND%
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY D. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE WE
MOAN LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
SUCI MISSOURIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE. JANE
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE. WE ASK THAT OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY MR COOLEY. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A REFLECTION INSPIRED BY
THE FORESTS OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
MORNING THE NEW YORK TIMES AND
THE BIG THREE NETWORKS REPORTED
UPDATED SURVEY AND BIG BASS AND
STATE PARK. CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST.
REVEALS MOST OF ITS TREES HAVE
SURVIVED THE FIRES. THOSE WORDS
SOME OF WHOSE TREES WERE YOUNG
AT THE TIME OF THE ROMAN EMPIRE.
WE'RE NOISY WITH LIVE YESTERDAY
WAS SQUAWKING STELLAR JAYS AND
INDUSTRIOUS WOODPECKERS. THIS
NEW NOTWITHSTANDING CALIFORNIA
FOR SOME OR ALL OF OUR MINDS
TODAY. AND IT IS RIGHT THAT
THEY SHOULD BE TRUE. THREE
SEVEN UNDENIABLE MAJESTY. A
DECADE AFTER BIG BASS WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN OH TWO.
THE AMERICAN POET JOYCE KILMER
GANDER MORTALITY WHEN HE WROTE.
I THINK THAT I SHALL NEVER SEE
A POEM LOVELY AS A TREE. TREES
WHETHER ABOUNDED ON A HILLSIDE
OR MAGNIFICENT WITH THE
LOVELINESS OF A LOAN SILHOUETTE.
ARE THE WORK OF YEARS. THEY ARE
SCOLDED ACCORDING TO THE WINDS
TO BLOW THROUGH THEM. THOSE
WINDS ARE INVISIBLE. BUT THEY
LEFT THE MOVE BRANCHES AS A
TIME WHEN AMONG THEM. PUSHING
IN SHAPING EACH BALLOT BUT AS
THEY GROW. EACH NEEDLE RELIEF
MUST ADAPT TO THE WINS OR BE
CARRIED AWAY. THE TRUCKS
THEMSELVES GROW IN BULK TO
SUPPORT THE LIVING AND GROWING
BRANCHES. A HILLSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA TREES IS A METAPHOR
FOR THE DYNAMISM OF LIFE. AND
JUST LIKE TO MARTINEZ TREES IN
THE FOREST. AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
SINCE ITS FOUNDING. HAS GROWN
AND BEEN SHAPED BY THE
INSISTENT AND FAR REACHING
CURRENTS. OF WE THE PEOPLE. AND
IN ORDER TO FORM A MORE PERFECT
UNION. BECAUSE OUR DEMOCRACY IS
DERIVED FROM THE LIVES AND
DREAMS OF OUR PEOPLE. THIS
POSSIBILITY OF GROWTH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IN. INDEED THIS
POSSIBLE OUR GROWTH IS
INSEPARABLE FROM OUR HUMANITY.
MATTHEW HENSON THE FRAME
AFRICAN AMERICAN ARCTIC
EXPLORER SAID AT THE START OF
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY. LIFE IS
GROWTH MY FIRST PROGRESS AND
PROGRESS DEPENDS ON NEW IDEAS.
WITHOUT THE ADVENT OF NEW IDEAS
WE SHOULD STILL BE RIDING STAGE
COACH AND READING BY THE LIGHT
OF TALLOW CANDLES. GREAT IDEAL
SAID REPREHENSIBLE THE GLORY OF
MANAL. NO OTHER CREATURE CAN
HAVE THEM. ONLY MAN CAN GET A
VISION AND INSPIRATION THAT
WILL LIFT HIM ABOVE THE LEVEL
OF HIMSELF. AND SENT HIM FORTH
AGAINST ALL OPPOSITION IN ANY
DISCOURAGED. TO DO AND TO DARE
AND A COP WITH WONDERFUL AND
GREAT THINGS FOR THE WORLD FOR
HUMANITY. FURTHER IN THE HOLE
OPEN POSSIBILITIES OF OUR
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS VERY
CLEARLY THE WORK OF OUR DAY. IT
IS A POSITIVE WORK TO THWART
THE IMPULSE OF TURNING. TWO
BOTTLE DECENCY AND RESPECTFUL
COLLABORATION AND HUMAN
PROGRESS. AND KEEP FAITH WITH
THE VISION OF OUR NATION'S
FOUNDERS AND ITS CONSTITUTION.
THIS WEEK WE CONTINUE THAT WORK.
LET ME SEVERAL WE ARE DONE THEN
ON OUR DAY. THE TREE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY GREW TALL
AND STRONG. AMID THE BLOWING
WINDS OF CHANGE SHOULD PROSPER.
AS A REFUGE OF LIES. AND THE
SOUNDS OF VIBRANT LIFE. AND DID
NOT BECOME A SILENT AND EMPTY
RELIC. THANK YOU MR COOLEY WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
GREAT FLAG AS WE HEAR THE WORDS
WHAT WE FIGHT FOR. READY I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SAN. IS A LITTLE. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
CINEMATIC NINETY AM WE ARE WILL
COVER MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
TO FOR TO PARK A DECIS
INCLUDING ALMOND THE ROLE
CALLED THE SOME MEMBER WHICH
MOVIE COOPER AND WE CARRIED OUT
OF THE ERROR CALL MOVES. MISTER
FLORES SECONDS THE READING OF
THE PRE DAY'S BE THIS WITH.
PRESENTATION TEMPERATURE. THERE
ARE. ENTER REFERENCE BILLS WILL
BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM FRAZIER FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUFFY WICKS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BIGELOW
BROKE GIPSON COOPER CARILLO TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. H. R. ONE OF FIVE
JONES SAWYER IS AT THE DESK I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
OUR O THE RESOLUTION TO THIRD
READING FILE TO ALLOW THE OTHER
TO TAKE IT UP LATER THIS WEEK.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I MOVED A
SENTENCE I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY EIGHT THE
ONE DAY NOT WAITING REPEAT
WAITING PERIOD TO REMOVE BILL
FROM THE AN ACTIVE FILE TO
ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THE MEMBERS TODAY. I TO ME
NINE SB SIXTY GALGIANI BY
HOLDEN I TO ME THIRTEEN SB SIX
SIXTY EIGHT RUBIO BY RUBIO ITEM
A SIXTEEN S. B. FIFTY FOUR
ALLEN BY GONZALEZ. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THERE IS A LIST OF BILLS
AT THE DESK WHERE SIDES AGREED
TO ADOPT FLOOR AMENDMENTS WITH
A SINGLE VOICE VOTE I WOULD ASK
THAT THE CLERK READ THE BILL'S.
WITHOUT OBJECTION COVERING.
ITEM TO SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
WOULD ITEM FORCIBLE THREE SIXTY
NINE WEBER ITEM FOURTEEN SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SIX KAMLAGER
I'M TWENTY THREE CYNICAL TEN
SIXTY FOUR KALRA. ITEM TWENTY
FIVE CYNICAL TEN EIGHTY FIVE
GONZALEZ I AM TWENTY EIGHT SEP
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BURKE. I AM
THIRTY TWO SYMBOL TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN BURKE. ADAM THIRTY FOUR
SINGLE TWELVE NINETY NINE
GABRIEL I'M THIRTY NINE TO THE
BILL THIRTEEN ONE DALY I'M
SIXTY SIX AND A BILL SIXTY
EIGHT HOLDEN. I'M SIXTY SEVEN
SO THE BILL IS SIX SIXTY EIGHT
RUBIO I'M SIXTY NINE SYMBOL
FIFTY FOUR GUNS. ITEM EIGHTY
FORCING A BILL LEVIN TO CALL. I
EIGHTY FIVE CYNICAL TO FORTY
NINE OKAY. ITEM NINETY THREE
FOR JONES. ITEM NINETY FIVE
NINE BEFORE A- I DON'T WANT TO
THREE THIS. BILL SO FIFTY SO
FRIEDMAN I DON'T WANT TO FIVE
SINCE. FOR GABLE. ITEM ONE
TENDS TO THE BILL NINE A CABLE.
ON ONE ELEVEN SUPER TEN TWELVE
AROUND AT. I WANT THREE TEAMS
LEVIN SIX PETRIE-NORRIS. ADAM
ONE SIXTEEN TO TWELVE SEVEN IS
A AND HOW TO WANT TO SENATE
BILL. FOUR ONE BURKE ADAM ONE
TWENTY CYNICAL FORTY SOME THREE
ACT. ITEM WANT TWENTY THREES
BILL ELEVEN SIX JONES SAWYER
HOW TO ONE FOURTH. TWELVE FOUR
BY. I DON'T WANT ONE FIVE SO IN
A BILL SIX YOU KNOW GRAY I
DON'T WANT TO SIX IN A BILL TO
ENTER DAVID CHIU. ADAM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SYMBOL SIX SEVEN
WE- ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE SYMBOL
A NINETEEN. LEE AND I DON'T
WANT TO SYMBOL. EIGHTY TWO. ALL
THOSE IN. SAY AYE. LOS NAY. THE
EYES HAVE A THE MEMBERS ARE DR
BILL ARE OUT TO PRINT TO BACK
ON FOR. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
GET RECOGNIZE GRADING THANK YOU
TO THE CALL FOR READ THAT FOR
ME. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS TO
SYSTEM IT SAYS ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY NINE TWO ALLOWS MEMBER.
TO UP AS LATE. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SEVEN NINE FOUR TODAY. A
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL
BE THE OR.
MEMBERS I COULD HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION. TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY CLASS OF THE
JESSE UNRUH ASSEMBLY FELLOWS.
THERE IS LIKE NO OTHER DUE TO
THE UNIQUE WORK CONDITIONS THEY
HAVEN'T HEARD DUE TO THE COLD
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
FELLOWSHIP WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN. IT IS ONE
OF THE NATION'S OLDEST AND MOST
PRESTIGIOUS FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS.
IT OFFERS ASPIRING PUBLIC
SERVANTS OF ALL AGES AND
BACKGROUNDS THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECTLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND CONTINUE ON AS
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AT THE
COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM.
DURING THEIR ELEVEN MONTH
TENURE WITH US THE ASSEMBLY
FELLOWS HAVE SERVED US IN A
WIDE RANGE OF STAFF FUNCTIONS.
NEARLY HALF OF THE OFFICES IN
THE LEGISLATURE EMPLOYING
FORMER FELLOWS FROM THE
EXECUTIVE JUDICIAL SENATE OR
ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS.
OTHER FORMER FELLOWS ARE NOW
MEMBERS OR OFFICERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES UNIVERSITY INSTRUCTORS
EXECUTIVES OR COMMUNITY
LEADERS. IN SHORT THEY GO ON TO
DO GREAT THINGS. PLEASE HOLD
YOUR APPLAUSE UNTIL ALL OF THE
NAMES HAVE BEEN READ COLLEAGUES
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
JESSE UNRUH ASSEMBLY FELLOWS
AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG
WE ARE CURRY IS SHANNON FLOORS
IS A GRADUATE OF YALE COLLEGE.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA IS BENJAMIN NASH HE IS
A GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
OUR QUE HAN IS ANDREW BLAND HE
IS A GRADUATE OF MAJORITY STILL
OF LAW AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN THIS
JUSTIN GLOCK SHE IS A GRADUATE
OF POMONA COLLEGE. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA IS ALMOST-
SHOW SHE SHE IS A GRADUATE OF
PACIFIC UNION COLLEGE. WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN S.
GLORY KHLOE ARMENIA SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF CLAREMONT MCKENNA
COLLEGE. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU IS
JULIANA PROPOSAL SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS. WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA IS
JAKE WATKINS HE IS A GRADUATE
OF CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IS DANNY DEARLY SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY EDUARDO GARCIA'S
STEVEN JIMENEZ HE IS A GRADUATE
OF UC BERKELEY. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER IS
KAYLA COOPER SHE IS A GRADUATE
OF SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN IS LILLIAN TO. SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
JULIO MENDEZ VARGAS HE IS A
GRADUATE OF YOU SEE LOS ANGELES.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO IS TO SHARA GUNA SEKAR
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF SCRIPTS
COLLEGE. WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER IS JORDAN PUT ON A
KIND OF A HOME HE IS A GRADUATE
OF UC DAVIS. MEMBERS WE ARE
ALSO JOINED BY GAS FROM THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA STUDIES
IN THE ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
SERVICE THIS YEAR PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A- HEALTHY ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR THE- FAMILY.
MEMBERS YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE A SECOND ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AS WE SKIPPED ONE
FELLOW DAVID. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FUNGUS GRIFFIN
BOVEE HE IS A GRADUATE OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORRECT SENATE
BILL 1-029-214-2753
694-649-3550 559-259-6660 SEVEN
SEVEN TWENTY NINE SEVEN FORTY
ONE SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX EIGHT OH THREE
EIGHT FIFTY TWO A FIFTY FIVE
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE NINE AWAIT
912-973-1040. FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOUR TEN SIXTY FIVE TEN EIGHTY
FIVE ELEVEN ELEVEN ELEVEN
THIRTY ELEVE TWELVE NINETY NINE
THIRTEEN A. ONE THIRTEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THIRT NINE
NINETY FIVE OF THE MINUTES NINE
WITH MINUTES TO NINETY TWO WITH
A MINUTE'S FIVE FIFTY NINE WITH
THE MERITS. AND SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY FOUR WITH A MINUTES. ALL
BILLS HAVE ANY MORALE AND A-
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ITEMS
ON RECONSIDERATION. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THROUGH. SEVENTY FOUR
ARE TO BE CAN. ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE. FILE NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO. FILE ITEM.
SIX THERE. WERE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVEN SIX MAY A THIRTY
THREE BY MISTER COURT SOME
PEOPLE THREE BY SOME WE'VE EVER
ACCOLADE OF THE PART OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
AUTHORIZES FEE INCREASES FOR
THE BOARD OF ACUPUNCTURE
BEHAVIORAL SCIENTISTS SCIENCES
AND PODIA ETTRICK MEDICINE OF
THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. AS THE PRESCRIPTION
DRUG MANAGEMENT SYSTEM NOT A
SECURE AS RECENT AMENDMENTS
REDUCE THE CURES FEET TO
INCREASE. FREE FEE INCREASED TO
ELEVEN DOLLARS FOR TWO YEARS
FROM TWELVE DOLLARS STARTING
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
NINE DOLLARS BEGINNING APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO ALIGN
WITH THE CURRENT FEE SCHEDULE
IF REVENUES EXCEED ROUTE
REASONABLE REGULATORY COSTS
THIS BILL AUTHORED ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO REDUCE THE
FEE. TO THE REASONABLE
REGULATORY COSTS. THESE FEE
INCREASES PREVENT THESE
PROGRAMS FROM GOING INSOLVENT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CREATING ENDS CREATING
SIGNIFICANT LICENSING BACKLOGS.
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION AND
THESE ARE THESE THESE FEE
INCREASES ARE NECESSARY.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT RAISE THE
FEES ON THEIR OWN BUT THEY CAN
REDUCE THEIR FEES AND SO THIS
IS IMPORTANT TO KEEP THESE FUND
FROM GOING SOLVING A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
IT WAS CALDERON MISTER FLORES.
THANK YOU MISTER I RISE AND
SUPPORT IS BILLING THIS MAYBE
YOUR LAST POTENTIALLY ON THE
FLOOR THAT'S CORRECT COUPLE
MORE NEVER MIND BUT DO I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR TO NEGOTIATE THE REASON
FEE FOR HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONERS. REQUIRED TO
UTILIZE THE KERRS DATABASE I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE POINT WAS
MADE A SILLY BMPS DURING THE
DISCUSSION AND NOTED IN
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE
PLACEMENT OF THE CURES DATABASE
IT'S CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA
JOINED THE REST OF THE NATION
IN ADOPTING A TREATMENT BASED
PERSPECTIVE FOR OPIOID
ADDICTION THE VAST MAJORITY
STATES HAVE ALREADY MOVED THEIR
VERSION OF CARE SYSTEMS INTO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
AND THIS TIME IT CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS US AS WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH FOR.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY CLOSE YOU WISH I WILL TAKE
MY COLLEAGUES WORDS AS MY
CLOTHES AND RESPECT LASSEN AYE
VOTE. LOCAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADAM. MISTER
CALDERON LAST BILL ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE TO HAVE.
ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. SEVEN THE THIRD
READING FILE PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS SEVENTY SEVEN
THROUGH.
EIGHTY ONE. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO SB
THREE TWELVE. CORKERY SENATE
BILL THREE TWELVE BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACCOLADE A COSMETICS.
DR QUIRKY MEHLMAN THANK YOU
SPEAK TO A MEMBER. SB THREE ONE
Q. REQUIRES DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENTS IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT APPEAR ON
DESIGNATED AND AUTHORITATIVE
HAZARDOUS. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THOUSANDS OF
CHEMICALS ARE USED CORRECTIVE
FRAGRANCES AND FLOWERS.
COMPRISE THE BEAUTY AND
PERSONAL PRODUCTS WE USE EVERY
DAY. SOME OF THESE CHEMICALS
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS. EXPOSURE TO
THESE CHEMICALS CAN ALSO
SUPPRESS YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM AND
COMPROMISED IMMUNITY WHICH CAN
MAKE INDIVIDUALS MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE. CALVET NINETEEN.
THIS ISN'T REST THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES FAMILY CANNOT THEIR
GAME THIS. THIS HAS STRONG FOR
FIFTY LATER NINE PER TO
HEALTHCARE FOOD TWENTY EIGHT
BUSINESSES. INCLUDING YOU
UNILEVER CAR AND PROCTER AND
GAMBLE. S. THREE ONE AS NO UP.
I RESPECTFULLY YOUR I'VE. THEY
GET A COURT. SEE NO DISCUSSION
OF ON THE ITEM CARCLUB RURAL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS WERE OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS FOR OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROADSIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE
SETS OF AMENDMENTS. THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING AT THIS TIME.
THESE ARE AMENDMENTS TO SENATE
BILL. TWO SEVEN FIVE. CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE OF
THE MEMBERS BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS
RESPOND TO CONCERNS RAISED BY
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
PLANNED PARENTHOOD C. PCA THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALIZATION
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES AMONG OTHER THINGS
THESE AMENDMENTS DELAY THE PP
INVENTORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
CLINICS FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS
OR DEDUCTION REGULATIONS
WHICHEVER IS LATER. REDUCED THE
PP INVENTORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CLINIC COMMUNITY TO THIRTY
DAYS OF SEARCH CONSUMPTION GIVE
CLINICS THE ABILITY TO COMPLY
BY ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT
WITH THE MANUFACTURER OR
DISTRIBUTOR INSTEAD OF
MAINTAINING THE INVENTORY ON
SITE. REDUCE THE MAXIMUM FINE
FOR CLINICS FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER VIOLATION
TO ONLY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN A CALENDAR
YEAR REDUCE THE MAXIMUM
STOCKPILE TO FORTY FIVE DAYS OF
SEARCH CAPACITY FOR HOSPITALS
AND OTHER LARGE EMPLOYERS AND
FOR THE STATE'S STOCKPILE. THE
MINUTES ALSO MAKE OTHER
CONCESSIONS IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS FROM THE HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY AND THE ADMINISTRATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. DAMOS
GONZALES SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT TO
PRINTED BACK ON FILE. NEXT UP
THIS IS MISTER GRAYSON SENATE
BILL SEVEN TO NINE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY NINE
OF THE MINUTES BY SOME MEMBER
GRAYSON THIS AGGRESSION ON A
MOMENT'S THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE CONTENTS
OF THE BILL AND WOULD INSTEAD A
PROHIBITIVELY FROM USING THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT
TO RECOVER CIVIL PENALTIES.
FROM AN EMPLOYER FOR REST A
MEAL BREAK VIOLATIONS THAT
OCCURRED WHILE WORKING FROM
HOME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. JAMES GRANT. GRAYSON
SAYING NO DISCUSSION ON THE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. JOSE NAY YES
HAVE THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT IN BACK ON
FILE. AND THIS IS MISTER DALY
SET UP ELEVEN FIFTY NINE SENATE
BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE WITH THE
MINUTES BY SIMPLY MEMBER DALY.
MR DALY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS TO SP ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE. THE BILL THAT SEEKS TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE
FOR FRONT LINE WORKERS
FIGHTING. KOVEN NINETEEN. VIRUS
THESE AMENDMENTS CODIFY RECENT
NEGOTIATION AMONG THE AUTHOR
SENATOR HILL IN A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION AND BRING THE BILL
INTO FINAL FORM. WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL BE A STRONG VITAL BILL
THAT WOULD PROTECT OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND EXTEND
MEDICAL TREATMENT. TO THE FRONT
LINE WORKERS CAUGHT IN ANY TYPE
OF WORKPLACE OUTBREAK. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. DANISH DALY
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HOW THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED. BILLS AT
THE PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE. SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN TO NINE
PORTANTINO TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AND ITEM
NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE SB EIGHT
NINETEEN SENATE BUDGET OFFICE
SCORE VIEW TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE. BACK IN FILE
ORDER PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE. WE HAVE DISPENSED
A FILE ITEMS EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SIX AND EIGHTY
SEVEN. THIS BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT.
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
CORKERY. SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BY CENTER BY CAL
SKI INOCULATING CIVIL ACTIONS
MR BONTA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI. SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT EXPANDS THE
LIST OF JUDGMENT EXEMPTIONS
UNDER CALIFORNIA BANKRUPTCY LAW
IN ORDER TO INCLUDE FAMILY
SAVINGS IN A CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARS SHARE FIVE TWENTY
NINE. COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT
ONE OF THE GREATEST HURDLES
FAMILIES FACE WHEN
CONTEMPLATING WHETHER TO PURSUE
A POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION IS
THE SKYROCKETING COST OF
ATTENDING COLLEGE. AND MANY
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES CERTAINLY
SEE GREAT VALUE IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND MAKE IT A
PRIORITY. TO HELP THEM PREPARE
BY SAVING UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN FAMILIES ARE
FACED WITH CHALLENGING
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. UNLIKE
RETIREMENT PLANS SCHOLARSHIP
ACCOUNTS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
AFFORDED PROTECTION. TWENTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES ALREADY
PROVIDE. STATE CREDITOR
PROTECTION FOR FIVE TO NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS AND
THIS WILL HELP INSURE THAT
FAMILY COLLEGE SAVINGS ARE
PROTECTED FROM JUDGMENT
CREDITORS THIS IS SPONSORED BY
THE STATE TREASURER OF THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
POLITICS. THEY RESPONDED SCENE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. OR CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ADAM. YEAH.
PARKWAY. CLOSER ALL TIRED I
FIFTY SIX KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS EIGHTY NINE
THROUGH NINETY TWO. WE
DISPENSED FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION GOING TO JUMP TO FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX THIS IS S. B.
EIGHTY SIX. MS FRIEDMAN JACKING
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR ALSO
ANOTHER IS AN ACCOLADE THE
PESTICIDES. IS FRIEDMAN EMAIL
PAN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PROUD 2% SB
EIGHTY SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ALSO I'M ALSO A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION THE
BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION TO SUBMIT
QUARTERLY REPORTS TO
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES AND THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
ON THE USE OF GRANULAR PRODUCTS
APPLY PARA FOSS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE CONTINUES
TO ALLOW THE USE OF
CHLORPYRIFOS IN GRANULAR FORM
IN SPITE OF SIGNIFICANT
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE THAT THE
USE OF THESE PRODUCTS INCLUDING
THE GRANULAR FORM PRESENTS A
WRISTER ARMWORKERS CHILDREN
AND MOTHERS FARMWORKERS ARE AT
RISK FROM THESE PRODUCTS WHEN
THEY MIX UNLOAD AND APPLY THE
PRODUCT WORKERS ARE VULNERABLE
TO HARM THROUGH EXPOSURE TO
SKIN AND INHALATION EXPOSURE
EVEN WHEN THEY FOLLOW THE LABEL
INSTRUCTIONS AND WEAR PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. CLICK
FOSSE'S ARE A CUTELY. AND
ASSOCIATED WITH IN ORDER
KNURLED MEN HARM IN CHILDREN.
CHILDREN CAN BE EXPOSED TO THIS
BRAIN DAMAGING PESTICIDE IN
VARIOUS WAYS INCLUDING WHEN
THEIR PARENTS OR SIBLINGS BRING
THE PESTICIDE INTO THE HOME. ON
THEIR SKIN CLOTHING AND SHOES.
PRENATAL AND EARLY LIFE
EXPOSURE TO CHLORPYRIFOS IS
ASSOCIATED WITH ELEVATED RISKS
OF REDUCE IQ. LOSS OF WORKING
MEMORY DELAYS IN MOTOR
DEVELOPMENT ATTENTION DEFICIT
DISORDER AND STRUCTURAL CHANGES
IN THE BRAIN. AS LONG AS
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS ANY TYPE OF
THIS PRODUCT INCLUDING GRANULAR
PRODUCT REMAIN IN USE.
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WILL SHOULDER ANOTHER RISK TO
THEIR HEALTH. NOW THIS IS NOT A
BAN ON THIS PRODUCT AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO STATE. THIS IS A
DATA COLLECTION BILL THE NOT
DATA COLLECTION AND REPORTING
WILL HELP PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
TOOLS THE LEGISLATURE SO THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE USE AND THE
IMPACT OF THESE PRODUCTS ON
THIS POPULATION. FOR US TO IT'S
GONNA RESPONSIBILITY TO AT
LEAST MONITOR THE USE OF THE
PRODUCTS AND MONITOR THE EFFECT
IT HAS ON THIS POPULATION OF
HIS PEOPLE AND CHILDREN WOULD
BE IRRESPONSIBLE. THIS WORK IS
NOT BE BEING DONE NOW. AND WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACTS OF WHAT WE KNOW TO
BE A DANGEROUS CHEMICAL WITHOUT
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK OF A
THREE MISTER. HERE RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU MISTER STE MEMBER.
BUDGET CUTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND- ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT THE
FINDINGS OF THIS BILL- WE ALL
KNOW THIS IS A DANGEROUS
CHEMICAL. BUT THE FACT IS WHEN.
CHLORPYRIFOS IS USED IN THE
PALLETIZED GRANULAR. FORM THAT
IS THE ONLY WAY WHICH WE ALLOW
IT IN CALIFORNIA THE FILTER
THEN SHUT DOWN. THEY SAY DO NOT
ENTER THE LET THE WORKERS KNOW
THEY LET EVERYBODY KNOW SO WHEN
YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT IT IT'S
KIND OF LIKE WHEN YOU GET YOUR
HOUSE BLOG IN THE PUT THE TEN
OVER IT. SO TO SAY. THAT
WORKERS ARE ARE CARRYING THIS
BACK IN THEIR HOMES IT IS
BASICALLY CALLING THE WORKERS
AND CONFIDENT WHICH WE ALL KNOW
ISN'T TRUE. BECAUSE THERE ARE
MEASURES TAKEN. STEPS PUT IN
PLACE. ALL THIS BILL IS DOING.
IS GOING AFTER IN USING.
DEFINITIONS OF SPRAY PRACTICES
WHICH WE NO LONGER DO. THIS
BILL IS GOING TO COST THE STATE
MONEY DURING A TIME OF
RECESSION I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
VOTING NO WERE LAYING OFF AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THERE WAS
MATHIS MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS COOPER FOSTER
IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
CHEMICAL. I WISH WE WERE
BANNING IT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL
OF RISK IT ACTUALLY REPRESENTS
NOT JUST TO THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE FARMWORKERS IN PEOPLE
ON IN THOSE FIELDS BY THE
DAMAGE THEY CAN DO IN THOSE
THOSE COMMUNITIES AROUND. THAT
THE FEELS LIKE IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE IT IT IS BEING USED THIS
IS REALLY SCARY STUFF THIS BILL
IS A MINOR BILL THAT IS LOOKING
TO COLLECT DATA AND HELPING THE
STATE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AND
IN MANAGER PRODUCT LIKE THIS
AND I HIGHLY REQUEST THAT THAT
WEPASS THIS TO GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED WE NEED WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS NOW-
OR WE'RE GONNA LOSE GROUND. IN
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA ASKS
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK MISSION
STONES SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM IS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
YES I WANT TO THANK. MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE DEBATE ON
THIS BILL THIS BILL IS A
COMPROMISE MEASURE. THERE ARE
THOSE OF US WHO ORIGINALLY
WOULD HAVE LIKE TO SEE A BAN N
THIS PESTICIDE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A MEASURE SO THAT A
STOP GAP MEASURES SO THAT. THE
OTHER SIDE THE USERS CAN SHOW
THAT THE CHEMICAL IS SAFE BUT
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S SAFE OR
NOT IF WE'RE NOT MONITORING HOW
IT'S USED. AND WHAT THE RESULT
IS ON THESE EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
IMPACTED. AND YEAH IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT IN A PERFECT
WORLD WITH ALL PERFECT
PRECAUTIONS THIS CHEMICAL
WOULDN'T BE AN ISSUE BUT WE
KNOW THAT IT IS. WE KNOW THAT
IT'S GETTING INTO GROUNDWATER
WE KNOW THAT IT'S GETTING INTO
WATER WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
RESIDUE. I'M REMAINING ON FOOD
PRODUCTS WE KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN
IMPACTING THE POPULATION OF
INSECTS AND POLLINATORS. SO WE
NEED TO HAVE THE DATA TO REALLY
SHOW THE LINK BETWEEN ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT OCCURRENCES AND
THAT MEANS THIS VERY SIMPLE
BILL. THAT REQUIRES THE
COLLECTION OF DATA AND
REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITHOUT AYE ORIGIN
AYE VOTE. AND WITH THAT
CORPORATE THE ROLE. HE SAID
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS
OUR VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TELEVISED FORTY SIX KNOWS
ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS NINETY
SEVEN. THROUGH NINETY NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED
S. THREE TWO. SEPARATE SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ACCOLADE IN THE
BUSINESS. MR STONE EMAIL THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT SB THREE FORTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHO'S TRYING TO
TACKLE AN INTERESTING PROBLEM
THAT HAS BEEN DEVELOPING OVER
THE YEARS AT AND THAT IS ONLINE
FRAUD OF TICKET SALES. THESE
VENDORS ARE GOING OUT THERE AND
USING DECEPTIVE PRACTICES LIKE.
DOMAINS AND SUBDOMAINS THAT
LEAD CONSUMERS TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE BUYING TICKETS THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE VENUE
BENEFITS ARTISTS BENEFIT THE
SPORTS TEAM AND IN FACT THEY'RE
NOT WHEN PEOPLE GET ON THESE
WEBSITES THINKING THAT THEY'RE
GETTING DISCOUNTED TICKETS
SOMETIMES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES OR THE ADVERTISING FEES OR
HOWEVER THEY FRAME IT. ARE
THREE TIMES WHAT THE TICKET
PRICE IS AND SHOULD BE SO
CONSUMER THINKING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO AN OFFICIAL SITE WHEN
THEY'RE NOT IS REALLY ARE HERE
TOO EASY TO BE VICTIMIZED BY
THESE SITES THIS IS A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD CLEAN UP IT'S
MAKING SURE. THAT CONSUMERS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE SENT TO
THE SITES THAT ARE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE TEAM
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE VENUE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE ARTIST.
AS OPPOSED TO BEING TRUE EASILY
PULLED OUT TO OTHER VENDORS
THAT IF SOMEONE WANTS TO HAVE A
SITE THAT GIVES PEOPLE ACCESS
TO OTHER TICKETS THAT THAT FINE
THAT'S THIS IS NOT GOING
AGAINST THAT. IT IS STOPPING
THE DECEPTIVE PRACTICES. THAT
LEAD CONSUMERS A STRAY AND END
UP COSTING THEM FAR MORE THE
DATA SHOWS THAT WHEN CONSUMERS
ARE. DUPED LIKE THIS IT
ACTUALLY HURTS THE VENUE IT
HURTS THE ARTIST IT HURTS THE
SPORTS TEAM JUST SO SOMEONE
ELSE CAN LINE THEIR POCKETS
THIS IS A GOOD BILL THIS IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION IT IS
APPROPRIATE. FOR US TO BE
PASSING THIS NOW GIVEN HOW HOW
MANY SITES THERE ARE IN THE
THIS STATE LEADERSHIP
NATIONWIDE ON TECHNOLOGY AND
FACILITATING THESE PROGRAMS.
THIS WILL HELP FACILITATE
CONNECTING VENDORS OR
CONNECTING CONSUMERS TO THE
CORRECT VENDORS THEY CAN MAKE
APPROPRIATE INFORMED CHOICES
NOT BE DUPED I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR STILL SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. GLOBAL ROLE. IS THAT VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WERE RESERVE
L. WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU
BUT I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASSWORD HANNAH
FILE ITEMS ONE ON ONE AND ONE
OH TWO. AND. ONE OH FOUR. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE OF
SIX SB NINE TWENTY ONE
CORPORATION. SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR DALLY
INOCULATING THE STATE HIGHWAYS.
THIS DALY AVAIL. THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SAMPRAS
THE TEEN S. B. NINE TWENTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR DALY SB
NINE TWENTY ONE IS THE DISTRICT
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW PORTION OF
HIGHWAY ONE SEVENTY FOUR WITHIN
THE CITY OF GRASS VALLEY TO BE
ANNEXED. FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION INTO THE CITY OF
GRASS VICE TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THIS PORTION OF HIGHWAY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR IS WITHIN THE CITY
LIMITS OF GRASS VALLEY AND HAS
FALLEN IN ILL REPAIR OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. AS A RESULT
OF THIS THE CITY HAS WORKED
WITH CALTRANS TO MOVE THIS
PORTION OF THE HIGHWAY INTO THE
CITY'S JURISDICTION. BY
ALLOWING THE CITY OF GRASS
VALLEY TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THIS PORTION OF STATE
HIGHWAY WE ARE ENSURING THAT
THE ROADWAYS IN GOOD REPAIR AND
SAFELY ACCESSIBLE TO RESIDENTS
AND VISITORS OF GRASS VALLEY.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER ALI SEEING NO DISCUSSION
WHAT A BET ON THE ITEM CARPOOL
OPEN. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE RALPH TELL
YOU WHAT I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN S. B.
NINE THIRTY FOUR. CORKERY
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE TAXATION. DR
CHOI YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS
SO I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF A SENATOR
BATES. S. B. NINE THIRTY FOUR
SIMPLY ELIMINATES ALL THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FILING FEE
ON NON PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SAW
FOR SUBMISSION OF THE STATE.
ZACKS EXAMPLE APPLICATION SO AS
WELL AS THE ANNUAL TEN DOLLAR
INFORMATION ON RETURN FILING
FEE APPLICABLE TO TAX EXEMPT
ORGANIZATIONS THIS FUNDING IS
ON. NOT CAPTURED IN ORDER COST
EFFECTIVE A TO BE ADDED TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD SO
AUTOMATED ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS
AND THE MUST BE MANUALLY
TRACKED AS A RESULT OF DORY'S
SAW ON NECESSARY INCREASE ARE
IN THE DEPARTMENTS TO WORK
ROLE. THE MANUAL TRACKING OFF
ON HIS FEES SO IS AN EFFICIENT
AND DA A CONTRIBUTES A LITTLE
TO THE GENERAL FUND ONLY A FEW
DOLLARS SO POOR APPLICATION FEE
IS SAW CONTRIBUTED A. FOR EACH
APPLICATION. THE OF THE FILING
FEES SO IT WOULD ALSO FREE UP
YOUR FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE
FOCUS OF THE OF TIME AND EFFORT
ON MORE URGENT MATTERS SO SUCH
AS- PROCESSING TAX REFUNDS FOR
FAMILIES. ENSURING ALL
CORPORATIONS TO PAY THEIR TAXES
AND THE RESPONDING TO THE NEEDS
OF THE CALIFORNIANS ARE IN
LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. LATER CHOI
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM CLUBCORP THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
HAS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
AWAY TO ONE OH NINE. AND. ONE
TWELVE. FILE ORDER WEIRD FILE
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN FILE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
REQUIRE ANOTHER PERSON ACTUALLY
IN THE CONTRACTORS MR LOW YOU
MAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE HELP FACILITATE X.
WITH. DIETING SOME OF THE
LICENSING FOR CONTRACTORS OR
SURPASS RIVAL. I THANKS LOS A
NOTICE SESSION DEBATE CORPORAL.
SACRAMENTO MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CULTURAL
TIE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE
IS FOR A PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS. ONE SEVENTEEN THROUGH
ONE NINETEEN. THE PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE. PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEM FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY
THREE. AND. ONE TWENTY FIVE.
AND ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
MEMBERS
WE ARE. AT ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN
TO MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MISTER
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE WITH A
HEAVY HEART TO HONOR THE MEMORY
OF OUR FRIEND IVAN ALL. WHO AN
EXPECTEDLY PASSED AWAY ON
AUGUST EIGHTH. JUST AFTER
CELEBRATING THE BIRTHDAY OF HIS
DAUGHTER. I HAVEN'T CAPITOL
CAREER SPANS FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WORRY BEGAN HIS PUBLIC
SERVICE AS A SOME WOMEN MIGHT
THE LINE'S CHIEF OF STAFF.
LATER HE SERVED AS CHIEF OF
STAFF. FOR ASSEMBLY- REPUBLICAN
LEADER CONNIE CONWAY AND THEN
BEGAN A CAREER OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING. AS A RESPECTED
LOBBYIST FOR CAPITAL ADVOCACY.
IN A BUILDING AT THAT AT TIMES
IS A PLACE OF DARKNESS INTO
THIS IS MISS. I'VE BEEN WAS A
RARE SHINING LIGHT THE GAVE
HOPE WITH A POSITIVE THOUGHT.
HOWEVER BIG YOUR PROBLEM. I'VE
BEEN WOULD HELP YOU STRATEGIZE
YOUR WAY TO A SOLUTION THAT
WOULD MAKE EVERYONE CONTENT.
WHATEVER THE TENSE SITUATION
WAS I HAVE BEEN WOULD DISARM
EVERYONE WITH A GOOD NATURE AND
PUT EVERYONE AT EASE WITH A
GOOD BOTTLE OF WINE. HOWEVER
LOW YOU MIGHT BE FEELING AND
TRUST ME WE REPUBLICANS HAS
SOME LOW MOMENTS AT TIMES IN
THIS HOUSE. I WOULD WOULD PICK
YOU. UP WITH HIS INFECTIOUS
LAUGH AND HELP YOU SEE THE ARE
OF PASTA. WHENEVER YOU SIAM
WHATEVER THE SEARCH. I'VE BEEN
WOULD GREET YOU WITH HIS
TRADEMARK SMILE AND OFTEN A BIG
HUG. WHETHER YOU WERE AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR AN INTERN
IVAN WOULD ALWAYS TREAT YOU AS
AN EQUAL. HE HAD A NON ABILITY
TO BECOME EVERYONE'S FRIEND
UPON MEETING THEM. THE PERSON
WHO KNEW HIM BEST AND WHO HE
WAS ALWAYS WITH. WHAT IS BEST
FRIEND MICHAEL LINES. MY CAN I
EVEN WERE BEST FRIENDS SINCE
COLLEGE. THAT'S CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY OF FRESNO THEY
WERE COLLEGE ROOMMATES. WHEN I
COUNTLESS TRIPS TOGETHER AND
RAISED HER FAMILY TOGETHER.
WHEN MIKE BECAME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I EVEN GAVE UP HIS
SUCCESSFUL LAW PRACTICE IN
FRESNO TO BECOME AS CHIEF OF
STAFF. TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
FLOOR IF YOU'RE LUCKY. IF
YOU'RE LUCKY. YOU WILL HAVE A
CHIEF OF STAFF WHO IS A VOICE
OF REASON WHO WILL KEEP YOU
FOCUSE AND HONEST WITH
YOURSELF EVEN WHEN YOU DON'T
WANT TO HEAR IT. I'VE BEEN WAS
THAT PERSON FOR MIGHT. HE WITH
HIS VOICE OF REASON. HE WAS THE
VOICE OF REASON FOR MANY OF US
ACTUALLY. WHEN MIKE WOULD THINK
SOMETHING WAS A HUGE DEAL. I
ONE WOULD BRING MIKE BACK TO
REALITY. BY TELLING UP RELAX.
IT'S NOT THAT BIG A DEAL AND
NEITHER ARE YOU COMING FROM AN
ITALIAN UPBRINGING FAMILY MEANT
THE WORLD TO LIVE IN. MIKE IN
IVAN'S FAMILIES WERE AS CLOSE
AS MY CONNIVANCE. THEY WERE
EACH OTHER'S BEST MEN AT THEIR
WEDDINGS THEIR KIDS WERE BORN
WITHIN A YEAR OF EACH OTHER AND
NOW THEIR SONS ARE OFF TO
COLLEGE IN FACT THE VERY SAME
COLLEGE. HISTORY REPEATING
ITSELF HOWEVER ANYONE WHO KNEW
I EVEN LEARNED THE SOME OF HIS
FAVORITE MEMORIES CAME FROM
TAKING HIS FAMILY SKIING IN THE
WINTER HOSTING BARBECUES AT
THEIR HOUSE GOING BOATING IN
THE SUMMER. I'VE BEEN WAS A
LOYAL FRIEND DEDICATED FATHER
AND LOVING HUSBAND. JUST A
GENUINELY WONDERFUL MA'AM. I
WENT MISSING I'VE BEEN
WANDERING THE HALLS AND COMING
INTO MY OFFICE. IS COMMON
DURING THE METER WAS RARE
AROUND HERE. HE ALWAYS TREATED
MEMBERS STAFF AND LOBBYIST WITH
RESPECT AND PATIENCE. I WILL
MISS THE MANY CONVERSATIONS
OVER A GLASS OF WINE WITH IVAN
AND MY- IN FACT I OWE MUCH. TO
IVAN. AND THOSE SPECIAL MOMENTS
OF GUIDING ME TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS AND ADVOCATE FOR
THE PRINCIPLES WE SHARE. THERE
ARE FEW PEOPLE OF WHICH YOU CAN
SAY THAT YOU BECAME A MUCH
BETTER PERSON FOR HAVING JUST
KNOWN THEM. I'VE BEEN ALL
TOMORROW. WAS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE. JOINING US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY OR IVAN'S WIFE A LESSON.
HIS DAUGHTER MARINA A SON
NICHOLAS. HIS PARENTS A GUSTO
AND LOUISE. IS IN LOSS MARLENE
AND JOHN AND HIS BEST FRIEND
MIKE. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THIS ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF OUR
SPECIAL AND DEAR FRIEND IVAN
ALL TOMORROW MISTER SPEAKER CAN
WE JUST TAKE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE. FOR IBM. THANK YOU. WE
WILL OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE UPON THE COMPLETION OF
THIS A. M. MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. I RISE IN
RECOGNITION OF OUR GOOD FRIEND
IVAN ALTA MORA. IVAN WAS A
BELOVED MEMBER OF OUR CAPITAL
FAMILY BOTH IN LEADERSHIP AND
IN THE LOBBYING COMMUNITY I
FIRST MET IVAN AS A FRESHMAN
LEGISLATOR I WAS A REPUBLICAN
WHIP UNDER OUR LEADER CONNIE
CONWAY. AND IVAN WAS AS
PROFESSIONAL AS THEY COME. AT
HIS SERVICE IT BECAME EVIDENT
JUST WHAT KIND OF AN IMPACT HE
HAD ON HIS COMMUNITY HIS CHURCH
HIS FRIENDS HIS COLLEAGUES. AND
MOST OF ALL HIS FAMILY. IN FACT
I DON'T THINK I EVER SAW I'VE
IN THE MATTER HOW STRESSFUL
THINGS GOT WITHOUT A SMILE ON
HIS FACE. IT WOULD BE MY HOPE
THAT EACH OF US TAKES TO HEART
IVAN'S EXAMPLE OF A LIFE WELL
LIVED. AND USE HIS PASSING IS A
REMINDER. TO GIVE OF OURSELVES
GENEROUSLY AND LOVE
UNCONDITIONALLY I'VE BEEN WILL
BE MISSED. THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU THIS WATER MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET
GERMANY MEMORY YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST I
WANTED TO ADD MY- CONDOLENCES
TO THE FAMILY AND- THIS MY
REMARK. ON THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT ITEM WAS I MEAN I THINK IS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE AND I THINK
WE CAN ALL ATTEST TO THIS THAT-
THAT LEAVES A MARK ON YOU
ANNAMYCIN. NOW GOING ON SIX
YEAR I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
SIX YEARS BE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IVAN WAS JUST ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHEN I FIRST
GOT HERE THAT. AFTER MY FIRST
MEETING WITH HIM AND THE MANY
MEETINGS THAT I HAVE WITH HIM
THERE AFTER YOU JUST. YOU GOT
THIS GENTLE SPIRIT THAT HE HAD-
AND THE CARE AND ATTENTION THAT
HE GAVE TO REALLY EVERYTHING
THAT HE DID. HE ALWAYS KNEW THE
ISSUE INSIDE AND OUT WHEN YOU
WOULD COME AND TALK TO YOU- BUT
YOU COULD ALSO SENSE THAT
DISICK COMPASSIONATE SPIRIT
THAT HE HAD. AND YOU COULD NOT
HAVE. RELATIONSHIP WITH I'VE
BEEN WITHOUT HIM TALKING ABOUT
HIS FAMILY. AND THAT WAS ALWAYS
YOU KNOW I THINK AT THE HEART
AND I'LL- I'LL ALWAYS REMEMBER
THE BETS THAT WE HAD OVER A
EAST NICOLAS VERSES BRATCHER
CHRISTIAN. AND I WILL REALLY
MISS THIS THIS MAN WHO I THINK
IS LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK- IN
THIS INSTITUTION AND I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER PART ABOUT ITEM
WAS THAT HE BELIEVED IN THIS
INSTITUTION YOU KNOW THIS HAS
BEEN SAID HE CAME HERE TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE- HE CAME HERE FOR
RELATIONSHIP AND I THINK HE HAD.
SO MANY GREAT RELATIONSHIPS
WITH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
AND YOU KNOW FOR ME IT'S JUST
IT IT'S A SHOCK IT'S A SHOCK TO
LOSE SOMEONE. WHO REALLY HAS
JUST BEEN SO FUNDAMENTAL TO
THIS PLACE AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
A PART OF IT AND- SO I JUST
WANNA HAVE MY REMARKS OF. THIS
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY IN
THE SPECIAL MAN AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY. MISAMIS INSTITUTION-
WILL MISS HIM. AND SO I HAD IS
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER AND PER MR
BIGELOW'S REQUEST MEMBERS
PLEASE RISE. AS WE OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE TO REMEMBER.
I'VE BEEN OUT TOMORROW.
THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY I'D ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE. TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
GREEN CARPET THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AT THIS TIME. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. BEFORE WE MADE A TURN.
MR BRO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR
YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARRIVED TO GERMAN THE MEMORY OF
WILLIAM LYON. A USC TRUSTEE
PROMINENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPER AND
DECORATED MILITARY VETERAN WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY SEVEN IT IS HOME IN COTO
DE CAZA. WILLIAM LAI WAS BORN
IN LOS ANGELES ON MARCH NINTH
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE I GREW UP
THE SON OF A BEVERAGE
WHOLESALER. BEFORE WILLIAM WAS
APPROVED ONE OF THE NATION'S
MOST PROMINENT RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPERS HE PURSUED A CAREER
IN AVIATION. IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES FOLLOWING HIS
UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MISALIGNED ATTENDED
THE DALLAS SEAVEY SCHOOL AND
AIR COLLEGE WHERE AS A CIVILIAN
INSTRUCTOR HE TRAINED MILITARY
PILOTS BEFORE HE. HIMSELF JOIN
THE U. S. ARMY AIR IN NINETEEN
FORTY THREE. DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. WHILE IN THE MILITARY
SERVICE THE PILOT IN EUROPE.
THE PACIFIC NORTH AFRICA AND IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX. HE THEN
JOINED THE AIR FORCE RESERVE.
BOB TO RETURN DO IN EARLY
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND FLEW
SEVENTY FIVE COMBAT MISSIONS IN
THE KOREAN WAR. GENERAL LINE
WAS A DECORATED AIR FORCE PILOT
RECEIVED NUMEROUS MILITARY
AWARDS AND DECORATIONS
INCLUDING THE DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE CROSS. LEGION OF MERIT.
DISTINGUISHED FLYING CROSS THE
PRESIDENTIAL UNIT CITATION. HE
WAS PROMOTED TO MAJOR GENERAL
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND A
YEAR LATER HE TOOK A FORCED.
FOUR YEAR SABBATICAL FROM
BUSINESS WHERE IS APPOINTED
CHIEF OF STAFF OF THE US
AIRFORCE RESERVES. BY PREIDENT
FOR A POSITION HE HELD UNTIL
HIS RETIREMENT FROM THE
MILITARY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. AS A REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPER GENERAL LINE WAS
AMONG THE PIONEERS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S PROPOSED MORE WORK
TO ECONOMIC BOOM. OVERSEEING
MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GENERAL LINE BUILT
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOMES NATIONWIDE AND HELPED
SHAPE. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OVER
THE HALF LAST HALF CENTURY. HE
BEGAN HIS CONSTRUCTION CAREER
NINETEEN FIFTY FOR LAUNCHING
THE NEWPORT BASED. WILLIAM LYON
HOMES INCORPORATED WHICH GREW
INTO ONE OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST HOME BUILDERS. IT WAS
ALSO THE FOUNDING CHAIRMAN AND
BOARD A COMMERCIAL BANK OF
CALIFORNIA. GENERAL LINE ALSO
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF AS A
DEVOTED PHILANTHROPISTS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS. HE WAS THE
FOUNDING CHAIRMAN OF THE
ORANGEWOOD CHILDREN'S
FOUNDATION ALLEGE EFFORTS TO
BUILD WHAT IS NOW CALLED ORANGE
WITH CHILDREN AND FAMILY CENTRE
IN ORANGE COUNTY. ORANGE
COUNTY'S ONLY EMERGENCY SHELTER
FOR ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN. WAS ALSO A FOUNDING
BOARD MEMBER AND SECOND
CHAIRMAN OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER NOW
CALLED THE SECRET SOME CENTER.
OF ARTS AND PROVIDED A
LEADERSHIP GIFT TOWARDS THE
CENTER'S COMPLETION. LINES
PASSION FOR AVIATION HISTORY
LED HIM TO OPEN THE LINE THEIR
MUSEUM. A JOHN WAYNE AIRPORT IN
SANTA ANA. HE CONTINUE MAINTAIN
A RELATIONSHIP WITH USC SINCE
HE STARTED BUSINESSES AUTOGRAPH
IN THE FRTIES. WHERE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX HE WAS LEFT
TO USC BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
SERVING ON THE BOARD. FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS. HE BECAME
ONE OF THE MOST STALWART
SUPPORTERS. IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
U. S. C. AWARDED HIM AN
HONORARY DOCTORATE ALSO THE
GENERAL Y. LINE UNIVERSITY
CENTER THE UNIVERSITY PARK
CAMPUS MAINSTREAM RECORD CENTER
FACILITY. IS NAMED IN HIS HONOR.
GENERAL LYON IS A LARGER THAN
LIFE CHARACTER. WARM THOSE NEAR
TO HIS HEART. WILLIAM IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LEVINE
CHILDREN SUSAN. L. CHRISTINE
ROADS AND MARSHA STONE SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND FOUR GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE JOURNEYING IN THE MEMORY OF
GENERAL WILLIAM LINE. THANK YOU
MISTER BROKE. MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK THIS BODY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A ROUTE
OF ROME- DíAS WHO LOST HIS
BATTLE TO STOMACH CANCER IN
DECEMBER THE NINTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. ROAD WAS BORN JULY
THIRTY FIRST NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
AND MEXICALI BAJA CALIFORNIA
ROAD CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AT
THE AGE OF ELEVEN YEARS OLD HE
WAS THE OLDEST OF TEN CHILDREN
HE WENT TO LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND ONE YEAR AT CANOGA PARK
HIGH SCHOOL HE REALIZE THAT
BECAUSE OF HIS FAMILY WAS GOING
THROUGH HARD TIMES THAT HE HAD
TO RETURN BACK HOME TO MEXICO
TO HELP THE FAMILY THROUGH
THEIR FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES HE
RETURNED BACK TO MEXICO TO DO
JUST THAT. YEARS LATER AFTER
THE FAMILY WAS STABILIZED HE
RETURNED BACK TO CALIFORNIA HE
WORKED IN A WAREHOUSE WHERE HE
JOINED THE TEAMSTERS UNION HE
WORKED UNTIL HE RETIRED FROM
THAT JOB AS A WAREHOUSE
ATTENDANT. AND SET HIS ROOTS IN
WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA WHERE HIS
FAMILY HAS BEEN HEAVILY
INVOLVED ON REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE IN MY DISTRICT AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES ROSE
NEPHEW KENNY- WAS SHOT AND
KILLED AND LEFT TO CHILDREN-
BEHIND AND THE REASON WHY
REFERENCE THAT IS BECAUSE OF
HIS KINNEY'S OLDEST DAUGHTER MR
COLUMN IS JACKSON WAS IT IS
ELEVEN YEARS OLD SHE SPEAK
LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY A GUY TO
TRY TO CURB HER CREEK TRAIL GUN
VIOLENCE- IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ROSE SON RICKY ALSO HAS BEEN A
TRAILBLAZER FIGHTING EVERY DAY
FOR THE VOICELESS FOR THE LEFT
OUT FOR THE LOST AND THE
FORGOTTEN THOSE WHO SOCIETY OF
LABEL INVISIBLE. AND THIS IS
THE FRUIT IN WHICH RHODIA HAS.
HIS FAMILY CONTINUE TO BE VERY
ACTIVE IN MY COMMUNITY AND HIS
PASSING IS OF THE LOSS TO ALL
OF US HE LEAVES BEHIND A LOVELY
WIFE THREE CHILDREN AND BOTH OF
HIS PARENTS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF ROW ROW
D. S. THANK RISK GIVING YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED CONDITIONAL
INTERMARRY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A LONG
TIME CARSON CITY CLERK HELEN
CAL GOALIE WHO PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL SIXTH IN THE CITY OF
GARDENA SHE PASS AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF NINETY TWO YEARS OF AGE
HELEN GREW UP IN PASADENA BUT
DURING WORLD WAR TWO SHE HER
MOTHER AND HER TWELVE SIBLINGS
WERE AMONG THE THOUSANDS OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS PLACED IN.
CONCENTRATION CAMPS SHE WAS
EVENTUALLY. PROVINCIALLY ABLE
TO RETURN BACK TO PASADENA
WHERE SHE MARRIED THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE THEY OWN A CARSON
NURSERY- TOGETHER FOR ALMOST A
DECADE BEFORE SHE- BECAME A
PUBLIC SERVANT. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR HELLO CAL GOAL
BECAME THE SECOND CITY CLERK IN
THE CITY OF CARSON AND WAS
REELECTED FOR UNPRECEDENTED TEN
TERMS AFTER SERVING HER SITTING
IN THE ROLE FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS HELEN CALGEL RETIRED. IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN LEAVING
BEHIND A LEGACY WITH THE MANY
CALL MANY INDIVIDUALS CALLING
HER THE MOTHER OF CITY HALL SHE
IS BELIEVED TO BE THE FIRST
JAPANESE AMERICAN WOMAN ELECTED
TO LOCAL OFFICE IN THE
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. FOR HER DECADE OF
SERVICE THE CITY COUNCIL VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY IN I WAS IN THE
CITY COUNCIL WHEN THAT
UNANIMOUS TO NAME OUR COUNCIL
CHAMBERS AFTER TELLING CAL GOAL
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HELEN
CALICO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON. THIS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND HILDA
GARCIA A SOCIAL JUSTICE
CHAMPION WHO PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH OF THIS YEAR
AT THE YOUNGAGE OF FORTY
THREE. HELD IT WAS WELL KNOWN
FOR HER POLITICAL CAREER. SHE
FIRST CAUGHT THE POLITICAL BUG
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHEN
SHE SERVED AS A LAWN SIGN
COORDINATOR FOR THEN SENATOR.
RICHARD A LOT OF COHEN'S
HISTORICAL THIRTY ONE VOTE WHEN
CAMPAIGN. HER PASSION AND
DRIVE. WAS VERY EVIDENT. IN HER
WORK TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE. AT
THE PICO YOUTH AND FAMILY
CENTER WHERE SHE BROUGHT
ATTENTION AND RESOURCES TO
MINORITY AT PROMISE YOUTH IN
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AS
WELL AS IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. NOT ONLY DID SHE
SERVED AS A BOARD MEMBER BUT
SHE ALSO MENTORED SEVERAL YOUNG
PEOPLE DURING HER FREE TIME AND
DEDICATED HER TIME TO SHOWING.
HER MENTEES THAT THEY ALWAYS
HAD OTHER ALTERNATIVES OTHER
THAN GANG VIOLENCE. IN HER
LIFETIME HILDA BECAME A VOICE
FOR THE VOICELESS. THOSE AROUND
HER OFTEN DESCRIBED HERAS A
TEAM PLAYER SOMEBODY WHO WAS
PASSIONATE AND COMMITTED. WITH
A LOT OF THE TERMINATE
DETERMINATION. AND UNPARALLELED
LOVE FOR WHAT SHE DID. MANY OF
US IN THIS ROOM KNEW HER
THROUGH HER CAMPAIGN WITH- SEIU
SEVEN TWO ONE. HER LATEST
VENTURE WAS TO ORGANIZE RIDE
SHARE DRIVERS AND ENSURE
JUSTICE IN THE WORKPLACE. SHE
GAVE EVERYTHING HER ALL AND US
FOR NOTHING IN RETURN. THIS IS
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS SHE WAS
LOVED. AND Y. I MISS MY FRIEND
SO DEARLY. SHE HELPED ME GET TO
WHERE I AM TODAY. TO THIS
OFFICE. AND SHE CARED SO DEEPLY
ABOUT THE WORK WE DO IN THIS
BUILDING. THE LAWS WE PASS AND
THE LIVES WE HELP. SHE IS GONE
TOO SOON. BUT WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN SO LONG AS WE
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT FOR
INJUSTICES WHEN OTHERS REMAIN
SILENT. HILDA IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND WHO NEVER LEFT HER
SIDE MICHAEL MARTINEZ. PERRANCE
ANTHONY AT THE AN OSCAR GARCIA
AND HER SIBLINGS DAISY AND
OSCAR GARCIA. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I ASKED THE WE
ADJOURN IN HILDA BUT THE C. AYE
GARCIA MEDINA MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF BOBBY LEE VERDUGO A
DEDICATED COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
AND LEADER. PASSED ON EARLIER
THIS YEAR AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
NINE. BOBBY WAS ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT EAST LOS ANGELES WALKOUTS
OR THE CHICANO WALKOUTS TO
PROTEST DISCRIMINATION AND
DROPOUT RATES AMONG MEXICAN
AMERICANS ON THE EAST SIDE. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE
PROBABLY STOOD IN THE BACK OF
CHAMBERS WHEN THIS BODY FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND KNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE. OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT YOU GONNA WALK OUT.
HE WAS AND WILL FOREVER BE A
KEY FIGURE IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT STUDENT MOVEMENT A
MEXICAN AMERICANS AND CHICANOS.
WERE PUNISHED FOR SPEAKING
SPANISH IN CLASS OUR SUBJECT TO
DISCRIMINATION FROM
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS.
BABI HIMSELF RECALLED BEING
PADDLED OFTEN IN FRONT OF HIS
CLASSMATES FOR SPEAKING SPANISH.
THE EAST DELHI WALKOUTS
ENCOURAGED MEXICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IN TEXAS ANY MEXICO TO
STAGE THEIR OWN DEMONSTRATIONS.
IN AN EFFORT TO SEEK FOR
TREATMENT. BOBBY WORKED AND
DEVELOP PROJECTS AIMED AT
STRENGTHENING THREATENING.
LATINO FAMILIES. HIS ADVOCACY
EARNED BOBBY INVITATIONS TO
OXFORD ENGLAND. ASIANS
POSITIONS ON FEDERAL AND STATE
COUNCILS AND WAS A STRONG
PRESENCE AT LATINO HIGH SCHOOL
YOUTH CONFERENCES INCLUDING THE
CHICANO LATINO YOUTH LEADERSHIP
PROJECT GIVEN BACK WAS SIMPLY
WHO HE WAS. BOBBY'S LIFE
LESSONS HIS COMMITMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITY HIS LOVE AND PRIDE OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS HE WAS A
PROUD LINCOLN HEIGHTS TIGER HAS
LEFT A DEEP IMPACT IN MY LIFE
AND THE LIVES OF MANY OTHERS.
HE TAUGHT US OUR HISTORY HE
OFTEN SAID THAT CHICANO LATINO
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY AND
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF WHERE WE
COME FROM. THIS WEEKEND ON
AUGUST TWENTY NINTH MARKS THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CHICANO MORATORIUM. THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE VIETNAM WAR IN THE
MILITARY STATION OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. I KNOW THAT HE IS
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE. BUT HE WOULD TELL ME THAT
WE HAVE YET SO MUCH MORE TO DO.
INCLUDING THE NEED FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL SO THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS COULD KNOW AND BE
PROUD OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
JUST LIKE HIM. THAT FOUGHT FOR
THEM SO MANY YEARS AGO. BOBBY
WAS MY FRIEND HE WAS MY MENTOR
AND HE IS DEARLY MISSED. I
THINK COMFORT IN KNOWING THAT
HE JOINS HIS LINCOLN HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER SAL CASTRO. IN
HEAVEN AND TO DATE WITH TELL
ME. STEM PROUD STAND TALL
BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS A GOOD DAY
TO BE A CHICANO. BOBBIE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE YOLI AND
HIS DAUGHTERS MADDIE FELLA AND
MONICA. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
ASKED THE WE ADJOURN AND BOBBY
LEVER DOUGAL'S MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM
TOMORROW. THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH FLOOR SESSIONS
AT INE AM FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION UPON CALL
OF THE SPEAKER ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SINGING HER ENOUGH FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MR DAILY
MOVES AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH PARMI ADJOURNED
UNTIL. WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SIXTH AT ONE PM. WE ARE GERMS.